- Good afternoon, I think
it is good afternoon
by a few seconds.
If you're in the walkup queue,
congrats on making it in,
that was quite a line outside.
Note to self for next
year, need a bigger room.
My name is Jonathan Allen,
I'm an executive in residence,
Amazon Web Services.
What on earth is an
executive in residence?
Well, I've been with AWS over eight years.
Before that, I was actually a customer.
I spent eight years at Capital One bank.
My final role was as a divisional
chief technology officer
as Capital One moved
everything into the cloud,
I learned a lot of lessons.
I run in teams in cloud on that.
And in the last eight and a half years,
I and my colleague Stephen
who'll introduce himself
a little bit later on,
have spent time working
with over a thousand different customers.
And of course, in the
last year in particular,
the big conversation for us
in our executive engagements
has been like, what is
happening to our people?
'Cause as a leader, which you all are,
'cause you're in this room,
as the senior leaders track,
what is gonna happen
and how we are learning to
build these agentic systems
is absolutely crucial.
And certainly, one of my biggest learnings
being a CTO was it is
all about the people,
and where we're going on this journey.
So let's get started.
It's no surprise, of course,
for us that know the cloud
if cloud is peanut butter, and bless you,
strawberry jam is agile,
then of course, they go together.
And of course, AI is coming along to use
and use this powerful mechanism
to make this great sandwich, of course.
But there's a hell of a
lot more to it than that.
All of us in this room,
I'm sure have used large language models
by this point in time.
And we are well aware of
the rise of the vibe coder.
And certainly, the biggest epiphany
as I work with customers
that are pre-cloud still,
and those customers are in the cloud,
the biggest realization
for those in the cloud
is, oh my gosh, like the
large language models
instantly can generate my CloudFormation,
or my Terraform script,
or however I want to
instate my cloud setup.
But I need to do this
in obviously a very disciplined way.
So let's go all in into agentic,
let's look at building our teams.
And immediately sort of time out,
this comes with a challenge,
a huge challenge for us as leaders.
And this is a mental model challenge
because certainly all of us,
and especially those like myself
that come from regulated businesses
such as banks or financial
services industries,
today, whether we like it or not,
we have optimized largely
since the industrial revolution
if we're honest with ourselves.
For determinism, we want
a predictable output.
And while agile and cloud
have enabled a completely
different way of working,
largely, when I was running agile teams,
building on cloud, we're aiming
to meet a business outcome
or a goal in what we're doing.
This changes, this changes,
and now we've gotta deal with the fact
that non-determinism in
these agentic systems
is a feature, not a bug.
And the truth, when I speak
to executives like yourselves
and other leaders, this is
distinctly uncomfortable for us,
distinctly uncomfortable
as we're managing this.
And this is not that different
from managing any of our folks
that have really high agency.
Those folks where you
agree a goal with them,
maybe at the start of the year,
and you know they're
gonna find that right path
to get through it.
And certainly, we're used
to moving ideally away
from gates to guardrails.
So we put our teams together
and we've got this
hopefully straight road,
it's never a straight road as we know.
But there are certain quality markers
that we're looking to get
through these toll booths
is the analogy.
Through to these teams now,
where we've got agentic systems,
that have got memory requirements,
short term, long term,
context requirements.
This is more akin as I was kind of looking
for the right mental model for this.
It's like a river that
busts its banks continually
and reforms how it's gonna do that
is a very different shape.
But if we're really honest
with ourselves as leaders,
if we're really honest with us,
there's a quote here that
I think is very poignant
from one of the world's
leading advertising executives
who actually is really
good at understanding
how human psychology works.
And he says most business
is probabilistic,
but if everybody in
business wants to prove
or pretend it's deterministic,
so every spreadsheet is in
some way an act of pretense
because it is past information,
which he pretend has
wonderful predictive value.
And we have been doing that
and we do know what
high agency looks like.
But as I know,
as a CTO who was booked
from 8:00 AM to 8:00 PM
running from crisis to fire
because that's just the nature of the job.
I am juggling a whole
lot of balls in the air
from legal to scale to ethics,
to control to security and HR.
Now I've gotta deal with the
emergence of agentic systems
and my executive team
who is very determined
that we're gonna get value
as appropriate for our business outcome.
So we look at the people.
And those of you familiar
with Professor Scott Galloway
may have seen this quote,
"AI won't take your job,
somebody using AI will,"
which sounds great.
And then, you read this analogy
and I sure wouldn't wanna be the horse.
So how do we take control
both of ourselves as leaders
and to help our folks
who have delivered these business outcomes
to be aware of this journey on agentic?
And one of the things
that Steve and I have been putting
this presentation together
is to focus actually on what
is really going on in the world
and to use the research,
not just hyperbole.
And those of you may have seen
this report from MIT NANDA.
And this report, there's a
link on the page coming up.
Despite 30-40 billion in
enterprise investment into GenAI,
this reporting covers a surprising result
in that 95% of organizations
are getting zero return.
Now you can argue on sample size
and methods used to correlate that data.
We don't want to be in that
95%, we want to be in that 5%.
So let's look even deeper at the data.
Let's look at this report.
And by the way, all of reports used
or referenced in this
presentation are 2025.
There really is no point
in this world using data
that's older than that because
its relevance as we know,
just changes continually.
And this one's a really interesting one,
which economic tasks
are performed with AI,
evidence from millions
of Claude conversations.
I don't expect you to
read that, of course,
I've summarized it here
into visually stimulating content for you
that 37.2% from Anthropic
used for computer and mathematical tasks.
No great surprise for those
of us that have used it.
10.3, arts and media,
7.9, office and administration,
9.3, education and library,
6.5, life, physical, social science,
5.9, business and financial.
Now I do not extend,
I do not expect to talk
about the next detail,
but I know and have been asked,
having already done
this a couple of times,
people want the next level of detail.
So this is up there purely for you
if you wanna take a picture of it.
So how does that translate
into actually what's happening
in the US jobs market
'cause that's where we have data.
So we can see here,
representation relative to the US economy,
okay, farming, fishing and forestry.
Yeah, not really being disrupted,
no great surprise there.
In the atomic world,
legal and services was lower
than I actually thought
when I looked at this,
and so on and so forth
through to computer and mathematical.
For our industry, if you're
coming here as a developer
or a leader of developers,
or a CIO or a CTO or even a CEO,
we have many attend re:Invent,
then yes, the disruption
and usage is profound.
Certainly for me who used
to be a hands-on coder
for 15 years to be able to use Kiro again
to get back into coding
without having to memorize
all the individual syntax
has been groundbreaking for me
to actually produce
business outcomes again.
So when we look at this, that
yes, the disruption is real.
And the next epiphany as I
work with customers is this.
Change versus run models don't
make sense in a cloud world.
Now the truth of the matter
is many people still
have a change versus run.
And what do I mean just for those
that aren't quite with this metaphor
means I normally have
a part of my business
that is for change typically
in a projects context
and people are there to do
that, and then I have a run.
And then, when something
finishes and change,
it moves over the fence to run.
Now largely, cloud has broken
that model down completely.
Agentic destroys the old model.
Why does it change it?
Because now we need observable systems.
These changes, we need to be
on top of what is going on.
We need to be looking
at the floor limits that are occurring.
We need to understand the trust,
we need the context area and engineering
of these agentic systems.
So the big mental model to think about
is if you're still in a change versus run,
it is not gonna work for
you in an agentic world.
Customers are now organizing
around business outcomes specifically.
So if you are really
organized like this still,
and I put this purely on the screen
for how I see people organizing themselves
who aren't on cloud yet.
And I've put into silos,
I've operated in this model.
What you actually see in
this model, by the way,
is a lot of escalation and
matrix management of resources.
And while it makes so much
sense for us on one level
to put skills into teams like this,
I mean I've used to be a network engineer,
I've done software engineering,
I've worked in the client server team
and I was in a siloed team before cloud.
And after cloud that changes completely.
So you've really gotta challenge yourself
that this model will not get
you to that agentic world
because we're moving from
that world of, you know,
just in 24 months, 36 months,
you know, going from auto-complete
all the way to agents.
And we're seeing that massive acceleration
every seven months.
We're seeing at the moment
the doubling of size
of execution path of an agentic
system at the present time.
So that brings us down
around to five questions
that we're gonna lean
into in this presentation.
And we're gonna lean into the first one,
what tooling do I need for the teams?
Now this is not a tooling presentation,
but the two absolutely,
which we're seeing out there
are addressing this problem.
I don't know if you saw
the little animation
of the red eye on the raven by the way,
took a little time to do that.
Proof of concept lasted four
weeks, but you know what?
Hey it works on my laptop, right?
We need to like get away from that.
If it works on your laptop, awesome.
But production systems
don't run on laptops.
Production systems do take a team.
And if you're on holiday
and it doesn't work,
somebody needs to be around to support it.
And I think Kiro,
which you'll hear a lot about,
of course, at re:Invent,
and I'm not deep diving into Kiro.
But the epiphany for
customers I've worked with
that use this is that the drive
to spec-driven development
immediately gives
discipline to the execution
of how we're using these new systems,
to actually generate purposeful
outcomes on the backend,
aligned to business outcomes
that need reliability,
that need to understand disaster recovery,
that need to understand
the element of determinism
that we still try strive for
that we do want our system
to be online.
We do want it to meet requirements
that we've thought about.
So Kiro has absolutely changed the game.
And of course,
I'm sure you've already
heard about AgentCore.
So Amazon Bedrock AgentCore,
everything you need for
getting agents to production.
The big thing, the big
thing for my customers
is that final model on
the right hand side,
observability, what is going on?
Because of course, we're striving
for that determinism still,
of course we are, it's a human nature
that we want predictability,
but we're dealing with
a high-agency system
when we're building it.
So that observability thing
really coming through very clearly.
So cool, I've got Kiro, so
how do I structure my teams?
Well, before we lean into that,
again, another mental model
that we are moving from
builders to orchestrators.
This is tough,
I'm privileged to have
worked in IT for 30 years.
I started coding when I was nine years old
on a Commodore 64 in BASIC,
those of that did that journey.
I was very used to being a
builder, how to build software.
We are now moving to a
world with this tooling,
which we are orchestrators.
And that's a tough mental shift.
For our techies, that's
really tough because again,
that fear of replacement strives through.
But that Scott Galloway quote of,
I actually want to be in control of this.
It's something as leaders
that we've gotta in really
double down with our folks
to say far better to lean into this,
not be a victim to change,
but be in control of that
change by being informed.
And then, people ask me,
well, in the cloud and agile world,
typically I've had this mental model
that I've had different folks,
whether they're, you know, FinOps experts,
or software development engineers,
or security or data or
cloud developer DevOps,
or folks that are focused in UX and UI,
which we've seen certainly
since the rise of web apps,
and mobile apps.
And then, typically I've
got this product management,
maybe business analyst
coming in at the side,
and they're like, well,
how do I organize these?
Well, typically, no great surprise,
when I had teams like this,
I would structure them as
the business outcome needed.
There was no massive strict formula
to how many SDEs were in a team,
or data engineers or cloud engineers,
it was as the business problem required.
Although, I did take the ability
to put security engineers
outside of the team
'cause there's never
enough security engineers
to put one in every team.
And typically, there are a MATRIX resource
where you end up with a security engineer
assigned to multiple
teams to do AppSec review.
And typically, yes, most
teams now do have a person
in a business outcome team
running cloud and agile
to focus on that.
This isn't really massively
changing for agentic.
So when you, you know, you
look at this as a leader going,
I've got all these teams,
how do they work on agentic systems?
Hey, I've got Kiro, I can
do spec-driven development.
Well then, you start going,
hey, I can just have a small team now.
I can just have maybe a product manager
who might become a product
strategist, a business analyst,
maybe one or two software
development engineers
and agentic software engineer
seems to become a very
emerging title for these folks.
And then, suddenly, you
hear things like, hold on,
business analysis is now an agent.
So actually design lead
in this small team,
hey, now I can get to a market.
And I'm here to say, hold
on, not quite so fast.
Because those of us that are used
to running production systems at scale,
it takes more than this to run a team.
And more than this for
a team to be on-call,
looking after agentic systems.
And the really thing,
the thing that when we
look at production systems,
it's really important
that we actually think about 24/7 on-call
for these agentic systems.
Now right now, I don't see anybody putting
in charge banking systems
with acid-based transactions with agentic,
but they're building agentic
systems around that in fraud,
in customer service, in mobile,
and there's a lot of value there.
But you still need to support this,
and that traditional on-call
structure of human gets paid,
human investigators, human
fixes is changing right now
to AI agent gets alerted,
AI investigates, proposes
maybe an RCA, heavy language,
and a human will then get involved.
I have not yet witnessed
the customers passing over
to fully allow that,
but that is surely being
challenged right now.
And we are seeing phenomenal
usage of AI on log analysis.
So rapidly drawing logs in
and helping the engineers
hypothesize on what is going on,
that's having a dramatic
impact positively on meantime
to problem finding.
And this is also shown from
our own usage inside Amazon,
this sort of dramatic
analysis improvement,
detecting that signal to the noise,
and then allowing humans
to make that decision.
And of course, when you transpose that
to maybe your P0/P1 matrix,
I see most customers still doing this.
Which then leads us to the data,
and this is the area
where I see real focus.
The data not only remains
an organizational change
for most customers,
but its importance increases exponential
in an agentic world.
This isn't just about having databases
in your operational data
store or your warehouse,
or your, you know, your data lake.
It could be PDFs and typically
is PDFs in my experience,
it's still in people's heads.
And the truth is, and don't
feel bad about this in any way,
a lot of customers still struggle
even to create a unified data
catalog in their business.
And quick bit of advice
if you're on that journey,
business owner, technical owner,
for every bit of data
you've got is required.
Put your data catalog back
to the nomenclature you use every day,
as the parlance in your
business, super, super important.
But data engineers are where
the real need is right now.
Data engineers are
becoming more important.
And this is almost this critical
missing layer I'm seeing.
And when you look at the research,
the North American IT
leaders report from IDC,
leaders reporting 55% difficulty
finding data engineer roles.
So you wanna look, again,
this is always true,
by the way, in human history
when any general purpose technology
gets to a position where we
think it's gonna displace jobs,
it creates more jobs.
And there's always this
painful learning curve.
But data engineers are required,
you know, to build the pipelines
to manage those vector databases.
Yes, of course, we are looking
for self-managing vector
database to all S3
is a miracle service in my mind.
But someone's still gonna make sure
that the context of that data,
I was talking to a customer recently,
and they had 18,000
tables in their warehouse.
Goodness knows the actual line detail,
the column, the table
detail of all of those.
But somebody needs to
know what that value is
and what it relates to.
And by the way, typically,
humans have done a really
poor job of labeling those,
because the context of that
data change is massively.
So we still need humans to
work alongside these agents
to help understand that data.
And then, there's another paper,
which is really interesting for me.
Small language models are
the future of agentic AI.
Interesting, this one from Nvidia,
and I do see this playing out.
So large language models are
incredibly sophisticated,
we've all used them.
But when you're building
an agentic system,
actually, this tremendous
use in having a small model,
one of the customers I've
worked with actually built
a 20,000 parameter.
Now we're used to talking
about trillions of parameters
now with these large language models.
But a 20,000 parameter model
to do something reasonably
predictable for them
that they trained in SageMaker AI.
It was so efficient they could
run it on a CPU, not a GPU.
And it did what they wanted it to do.
And this is the rise that
we're seeing in customers.
So you're gonna use a combination
of what agents are created
appropriately for you
to solve a business outcome.
So actually, the real
challenge for most customers
is still a little locked
in legacy systems,
complex ETL transformations.
I mean when I'm speaking to most
of the really big FSI institutions,
they have ETLs or extract,
transform and load jobs
in the hundreds of thousands,
and typically, whatever
product they're using
to release their ETLs,
that team is normally a
bottleneck team in their mind.
So actually, when you look at
agentic and what's going on,
this focus on data is
still very legitimate.
Again, a lot of the data is still stored
in incompatible formats,
subject to data governance,
spoiler alert, we don't like sharing data
by the way, very easily.
Like, heaven forbid,
somebody gets to my data
and find something useful in my data
that I didn't know about.
So again, we've gotta deal
with that in organizations
of how do we get over
that, how do we set up,
and yes, a lot of the
principles in data mesh,
huge fan of the approach
from the author who originally
came out of Thoughtworks
and proposed that,
because a lot of it doesn't
care about the technology,
it cares on the human
nature of sharing that data,
but still understanding the
governance of that data.
And of course, we don't
wanna create duplicate copies
of that data, it needs quality monitoring,
and this is where the
challenge still rise.
So a lot of times when
people are putting together
these production agentic
systems, data scientists,
understanding how do I create that small,
if necessary, 20,000 model
to solve a task might just be a calculator
that you want that does
a particular calculation
that you want to be done
over and over and over
without invoking a really
large LLM each time.
'Cause of course, that's
a hell of a lot cheaper
for you to invoke that.
You know, millions of
times than a large LLM,
data engineers have always mentioned,
getting that data from A to B,
breaking down those human silos,
understanding how we release it,
absolutely required data analysts,
a lot of people say data
analysts have gone away.
Not really, because context,
and the rise of context engineering,
super important in agentic
systems, super important.
And again, while LLMs
can help us with this,
we need the humans to truly understand
who owns that data,
what's going on with it,
these 18,000 systems, 18,000 tables,
and again, a lot of customers
are still struggling with ETL.
So when you think about building a system
to solve that business outcome,
data remains crucial, crucial.
And that's why, for now for
a number of years at Amazon,
we've been focusing and investing heavily
on this zero-ETL approach
that's helping you get away
from the ETL longest poll in the tent,
a customer used it for me the other day,
which I thought was very poignant,
longest poll in the tent,
'cause it's always the slowest thing.
It doesn't matter how much resource
that they seem to put at it.
So moving away and getting away
and simplifying that cost and resources
and near real-time insights,
super, super important.
So let's look
and this next slide comes with
a health warning by the way.
It comes with a health warning
because it entirely depends
on the business outcome.
But what I do see
and Stephen and I have
looked at this quite closely,
is yeah, so we do see teams
that are building agentic systems
and supporting multiple agent systems here
are putting together teams
that have a product manager,
a business analyst, software
developers, data engineers,
data scientists as required.
And typically, in an Amazon,
we will normally have a
principal software engineer.
So in Amazon we call these P engineers.
We don't have architects
inside of Amazon by the way.
We have solution architects,
which handle your interactions
as an Amazon Web Services customer.
But inside of Amazon, we
actually have P-level engineers,
which is a very senior role,
and each team has a P-level engineer,
and it's their job to basically
ensure that the goals,
technical goals of that
team are being met.
And they also have a
lot of responsibilities
over making sure
that new software development engineers
coming into the team can shift
code and override problem.
And when we have a problem
that requires multiple teams to interact,
you know, we actually get
a bunch of Ps together
and they'll solve that problem.
Now not everyone has that model,
so it's far very far
more familiar to people
to have something like this
where at the end, you've
got an architect doing that.
And these job titles by the
way are incredibly fungible
at the moment, incredibly fungible.
And of course, multiple agents
are helping this team do their job.
They're going to build an
already building agents to help.
Now typically, I've talked
about the delivery team.
When you are touching
an established process
and bringing some agentic side on there,
you'll absolutely have a
sister or a brother team
coming alongside that,
that says, well, what's my
business process experts?
And if you're touching
a really complex flow,
that's gonna occur,
you're gonna have
business process experts.
You're gonna have, again, an architect.
You typically, I'm seeing every customer
put a legal representative in there,
a financial analyst, a data owner,
and again, a software development lead
who's an interfacingq
leading that technical side
that I talked about in the previous slide.
So it's almost like a two in the box model
for building these agentic systems
is what's coming to the fore.
This model in particular took
on an established product.
My colleague Stephen's gonna
talk to you in about Amazon,
about how we think about different stages
of product development
and how we put different teams together.
And yes, these teams are
gonna use different agents
or create their own agents,
absolutely, absolutely.
We're seeing that occur immediately
because they're using agents
and realizing they can
build these small agents
in SageMaker AI to solve things for them
to reduce their cognitive burden,
so that they can focus
on what really matters.
Because the world is
really changing quickly,
I mean this was a venn diagram
I looked at a little while ago
with the congruence
between software engineer,
data engineer, data
scientist and data analyst.
And that sort of middle bit
of the venn diagram there,
that blue where it
talks about SQL, Python,
Cloud services, NoSQL,
I think a lot of us are seeing
where that becomes the top of the T-shape
if you look at how you skill yourself,
that bar of cross-functional knowledge.
And this is actually coming to the fore
in context engineering.
So I need to understand the
context of the agentic system.
And if you're at the presentation before
where Johnny talked about a
leader's guide to agentic AI,
he talked about this in more detail.
If you missed that presentation,
it'll be online hopefully in
the next 48 hours on YouTube,
you can look at that.
He talks a lot more
about context engineering
and we absolutely see that
role emerging right now.
These systems have gotta
understand that linkage for data.
So again, data is is becoming
that critical, critical pole.
And actually, what we do
see is a role emerging.
And it's interesting, I was looking
at how Thoughtworks think about this.
This is Martin Fowler,
he's one of my heroes.
He came up with a strangler pattern
for deconstructing monoliths.
And he talks about it like this,
as computer systems
get more sophisticated,
we've seen a growing trend
to value deep specialties,
but we've found that our
most effective colleagues
have a skill in spanning many specialties
where they're starting to
explicitly recognize this
as a first-class skill
of expert generalist.
And that is emerging, particularly
for context engineering.
You need to understand what
is going on at the system.
And if you want to go and
look more at Martin's work,
which I fundamentally always
read when Martin has a blog,
he talks about these expert
generalists emerging.
And I think this for context engineering
and agentic systems again,
another emerging role, prompt engineering,
I don't think any of us ever thought
that was gonna be a role.
Context engineering
absolutely is, absolutely is.
And with that, I will hand
over to my colleague Stephen.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks Jonathan, so
I'm Stephen Brozovich.
I joined Amazon in August of 1999,
so that was a little while ago.
The world has changed a ton since then.
We've spent a little bit of time now
thinking about how agentic AI
is gonna be impacting both the work
and the roles in our teams.
And you might be sitting
here as a leader going,
but what does that mean for me?
How about my role?
How is that impacted by this work?
And so I wanna frame the
question a little more clearly.
As leaders, right, we
all know we're trying
to generate value,
and we have a limited
amount of time, attention,
budget and talent
that we can allocate
towards the work, right?
In his book, "The Day After Tomorrow,"
Peter Hinssen talks about
different categories
of work we can be thinking
of, the work of today,
which actually leads to current value.
Then there's the work of tomorrow,
which is gonna lead to
value in the future.
And then, there's the day
after tomorrow, right?
What's that thing that we're doing
that contributes long-term
value to the organization?
And as leaders, we know we're all supposed
to be thinking about these and
prioritizing appropriately.
We gotta focus some on today,
but gotta make sure we take
care of the day after tomorrow.
Now reality is, today tends to
insert itself uncomfortably.
It's that pile of emails we wake up to
that we weren't necessarily expecting
or that next meeting.
Today tends to dominate.
Now we know we're
supposed to carve out time
for tomorrow, right?
So we take additional time to figure out
how do we write that three-year plan
or work on next year's budget.
And we still intend to think about,
but and we know we spend
far too little time
actually doing those activities
of the day after tomorrow.
That's when we're looking
at that new technology
or a shift in our business
that could actually set us up
for an entirely different
direction in the long term.
And that's not even taking into account
the stuff of yesterday.
That's a kind way to put it.
But this is that shortcut
we took three years ago
and the tech debt is
rearing its ugly head today
and is demanding to be paid.
Reality is all the time we
intend to spend on tomorrow
and the day after tomorrow
often gets consumed
by the stuff of today.
Are we getting depressed yet?
Let me make it even more clear.
We still have to remember
all this stuff too
on top of the work that we're doing.
And at this point, we might
be feeling a little bit like,
we're the only ones not
enjoying the party, right?
All the glossy ads make you
think that every business
in the world has this figured out but you.
The reality is, most businesses
are figuring this out themselves,
but the clock is ticking.
Now good news is that
there are some patterns
that we are seeing your peers use
that are helping navigate these changes.
If you were in Ishit Vachhrajani's
session a little bit ago,
this will look a little bit familiar.
Here, four mental model shifts
that we see is key for organizations
that are successfully
managing these changes.
Now as Jonathan mentioned,
most of our organizations
are set up to deal
with a deterministic world.
And in that sense, it makes sense for us
to have this culture of
operational execution.
How do I do the job extremely well, right?
Avoid deviation from known good processes,
being focused on measurement
and individual optimization.
But leaders that are successfully
navigating agentic AI
actually see themselves
and their organizations
more like research labs,
this attitude of
continuous learning, right?
As continuous learners,
our focus needs to be on
shared experimentation,
embracing adaptation and
providing psychological safety,
so that we can learn from failures.
This mental model shift in particular,
requires us to look at
other areas of leadership
when we need to adapt.
The first of those, Jonathan
already made a nod to,
which is in a deterministic
world that makes sense for us
to govern through gates, right?
We can define the process,
we can control each action,
check for compliance
through checklists, right?
And audit for deviation.
But agentic AI is making
us confront reality.
Since we live in a probabilistic world,
we should probably be
spending less time defining
and refining the process,
and more time providing
strategic direction,
defining guardrails and
creating feedback loops
that allow for rapid experimentation
and continuous calibration.
When we live in a deterministic world,
it makes sense to manage the
business like a factory floor
because we can set finite limits
and measure and calculate
against those limits.
But successful organizations in this space
are operating more like trading floors.
How do I provide enough
autonomy to the teams?
But I need to have
real-time risk visibility
and I even need to have
adaptive circuit breakers
that can respond quickly
to emerging risk patterns.
And then, finally, it makes sense
to organize in functional silos
when we live in a deterministic world,
when we have a known set of problems
and a known set of solutions
that we can deploy against those problems
because those functional silos
allow us to be incredibly efficient
at doing the same thing
again and again and again.
But when there's rapid change,
that rigid org structure,
those sequential handoffs,
and the isolation of data systems
that Jonathan talked about,
sometimes make change
feel like it's impossible.
Organizations that are successfully
navigating these changes
actually respond much more
like an immune system.
They swarm and reshape based
off of changing customer needs
and challenges driven
by business objectives
and customer outcomes, not hierarchies.
Now if you'd like to dive
into this topic a little more,
there will be a recording
of Ishit's presentation,
but we also have a link to
a blog that Ishit authored
that dives into these mental model shifts
more significantly.
It's one of just many
topics that the executive
and residence team produces every year
of the challenges and patterns
that we are seeing as we
talk with our own customers.
But what I wanna do now
is shift as we talk to,
you know, in our team,
we talk to over 1500 different
organizations annually,
we're talking at that C-level change,
and we see that the patterns
and the questions that we get,
and we often hear from
our customers like, okay,
that's an interesting story,
but what's Amazon actually doing?
And in this case, this is a
very rapidly emerging question,
like how is Amazon thinking
about org structure
in an agentic world?
Like many of you, this
technology is challenging some
of our basic assumptions
about how we should organize
and get work done.
And with over 1.5 million employees,
that question is not optional.
We have a team of
organizational scientists
that are helping us
understand which patterns
are helping us, which
are hindering us and why.
Now the answers are shifting,
we are still learning,
but I'm excited to share
with you some of the insights
that we've gained
from this work inside
our own organization.
The first insight shouldn't
be too surprising.
Organizations that align
their operating model
with their business lifecycle phase
outperform those that do not.
Now some of you are probably starting
to break out into hives,
please not another conversation
about centralization and decentralization.
Look, we all know there are
some benefits to centralization
and others you gain from decentralizing
and granting team autonomy.
But what we've found is that
this model is too simplistic
and it often leads us swinging
from one end of the pendulum to the other.
What we actually need is an
organizational design model
that is adaptive to
ever-changing environments.
In addition to that, our
businesses are too complex
to be served by any
one-size-fits-all model.
So the emerging thinking
is that our organizations
need to be optimized around
three distinct tensions.
The first is speed.
As Andy Jassy has said, speed is a choice.
How much should you be
optimizing for consistency,
and when should your
primary objective be agility
and iterative change?
The second tension is resourcing.
When should you be
thinking about optimizing
for scale and efficiency
through shared centralized
resources and tools?
And when should your focus be on providing
dedicated resources for
business specific outcomes?
And the third tension is connections.
When should you be building
deliberately interconnected systems
for coordinating complex workflows?
And when should you be striving
to create more and more
autonomous activity?
Let's dive into each one of
these in a little more detail.
First, your customers
require different speed
versus reliability
depending on their context.
And so we find that organizations
that focus on consistency,
they gain speed through
systematic execution
and standard processes
that deliver reliable,
repeatable outcomes.
In contrast, agile organizations
position critical activities
close to customers,
enabling rapid feedback and iteration.
When it comes to resourcing,
your customers actually vary in their need
for specialized attention
or standardized solutions.
And so as we think about this,
teams want to drive efficiency
by centralizing delivery
and building common infrastructure
that scale solution across multiple needs.
Whereas in other situations,
we need those dedicated teams
to focus on core capabilities
with deep customer context,
delivering specialized
solutions for specific needs.
And finally, on connections,
because guess what,
your customers are actually the
ones who should be dictating
that balance between autonomous innovation
and integrated delivery.
Interdependent operations
optimize for end-to-end outcomes
through coordinated planning
and shared standards.
Whereas independent
teams maximize autonomy
by ring fencing work into logical units,
enabling direct customer signals
and modular decision making.
Now where you sit, the optimal
balance on each of these
actually varies based on business context,
customer needs and
organizational maturity.
These tensions aren't mutually exclusive.
Successful organizations
are thoughtfully positioning
different parts of their business
along each spectrum based
off of their requirements.
The key is not to choose
one end of the spectrum,
but to position different
parts of your organization
according to your specific
needs and regularly reassessing.
We see this pattern at play across most
of Amazon's businesses,
depending on the maturity
of that individual business.
Younger businesses often
skew towards depth,
they're favoring agility,
custom functionality,
but as the businesses mature,
they tend to skew towards breadth.
Because consistency, economies of scale
and cohesive user experience
become ever more important.
So let's follow that evolution.
As we're starting out,
we're gonna skew heavily
towards depth over breadth.
'Cause early adopters are the ones
that are using this new product
and they are seeking innovation,
and they will accept some
amount of imperfections.
So we're maximizing speed and flexibility
through small, dedicated teams
with direct customer access.
The breadth depth mix starts
to shift as the business grows.
Early majority customers now
join those early adopters,
but they bring higher
quality expectations,
while tolerating some iteration.
And so now we start to see the emergence
of hybrid structures of
dedicated and shared teams
because we need those shared
teams to support scaling,
and we still need those dedicated teams
for rapid iteration and adjustments.
As the business matures now,
mainstream customers start to
jump and they become dominant.
And so they're requiring
consistent, reliable experiences,
high quality customer support,
and structured feature request processes.
We shift our operating model
to balance established
processes with innovation
through horizontal platform
teams for core infrastructure
and federated product teams
for customer facing features.
As a fully business-
sorry, when the business fully matures,
late majority customers dominate,
requiring proven solutions
with comprehensive support,
predictable experiences,
and consistent quality
across all interactions.
At this point, our
emphasis is optimization
and efficiency through shared services,
automated solutions and support systems
and self-service platforms.
Now this is actually where
most organizations stop.
They stay at phase four, right?
Refining and squeezing efficiency
out of every single process.
But this is also where they
are the most vulnerable,
because that execution excellence
actually becomes the very
thing that prevents them
from adapting when
business climates change
or that new startup shows up on the screen
to disrupt their business model.
And so at Amazon we understand,
we like the phrase we say at
Amazon, it's always day one.
The need for that startup like flexibility
is important in phase one initiatives
like the NFL on Prime,
but it's equally if not more important
for well-established
businesses like home delivery.
And so we have to constantly challenge
our own recipes for success
because customer's needs are not static.
We need to shift our mix yet again
to inject fresh innovation.
In phase five, we now have a
mix of both loyal customers
and customers seeking new experiences.
And so we need different
value propositions for risk
for each of those
customers and the balance
between familiar and
innovative experiences.
We want to enable transformation
while maintaining stability
through sophisticated
dual operating models
and hybrid team structures.
We find that organizations
that are following an adaptive model
are far better positioned
to react when technologies
like agentic AI emerge.
In fact, I'd argue it's that
organizational flexibility
that has enabled Amazon
to weather all the changes
in customer needs and demands
all the way from our very beginning.
Rigid one size fits all
approaches just don't work.
The second key insight we've
gained is that organizations
that asymmetrically
allocate human AI resources
based on the type of work
outperform those that do not.
Like organizational models,
it turns out there is no
one size fits all approach
to agentic.
So let's look at resource allocation
across four types of work.
The first type of work we call strategic
differentiated work, right?
This is the work that
customers view as uniquely you.
It creates competitive advantage,
it defines customer experience
and directly enables key goals.
The next type of work we look
at is strategic enabling work.
These are the capabilities
that power your differentiation.
They support competitive work
and reinforce organizational culture
to achieve business outcomes.
The third category we would
call business essential.
This is the kind of work that's required
for basic operations
and near term success,
but it usually isn't tied
directly to market value.
In fact, most of this work is
the keep the lights on work
that you just have to do
to maintain market parity.
And finally, we would
call another category
of work business compliant work.
This is the work that's required, right?
For legal or regulatory compliance.
There's usually little
to no market return,
but it's essential for
keeping ourselves afloat.
So if we think about these
four work categories,
let's look at how Amazon
is currently allocating
human and AI resources
against these different
categories of work.
Who's involved in this?
Well, first, it's you, right?
As strategic leaders, it's
our responsibility to provide
that vision, that insight, the conviction
and the judgment to define
the business outcomes
and guide the work.
The next group involved in
this is AI and agentic work.
It's a combination of AI
agents and traditional AI
used to solve complex challenges
and sift through
mountains of probabilities
to drive results.
The tactical execution team is the humans.
All those roles that Jonathan
talked about earlier in the day.
Those humans are the ones
that are creating the agents
and processes needed to
achieve the business outcomes.
And then let's not forget,
there are significant portions
of our businesses still today
that can be made far more efficient
through simple automation
or by leveraging utility
solutions like managed services
from AWS and other partners
without reaching for
more expensive options
like generative AI.
So let's look at how we allocate these
into those different work categories.
Strategic differentiated
work is really the only place
where executive leadership is critical.
We have to set strategic direction,
define our own customer
facing competitive advantage,
and make high judgment decisions
on product design and innovation.
AI and agentic systems carry
about 25% of the workload.
We're leveraging machine learning
for things like advanced
targeting algorithms,
and we're using AI agents
for predictive analytics
and customer behavior modeling
to ensure competitive outcomes.
The rest of the work is
going to be carried out
by that tactical execution team, right?
They're the ones dealing with ambiguity,
solving those complex challenges
and executing strategic initiatives.
Notice here, automation and outsourcing
are next to non-existent
because there's no known
solutions yet to automate,
and we would never want to
outsource our differentiator.
As we move into strategic enabling work,
the leadership team can take a back seat.
Our role changes to one more
of auditing and advising.
Now is when we can start
to look at the things
of tomorrow and the day after tomorrow,
because we've set those guardrails
that empower our teams to go and build.
AI systems take on a greater
percentage of the work.
They're tackling things
like insight generation,
anomaly detection, and
process optimization.
On the human side,
technical program managers
and solution architects take the lead
for technical implementation
and for cross function coordination.
Now we start to see the
beginnings of automation
and the use of utility solutions
for things like routine
coordination of activities
and basic workflow management.
When we look at business essential work,
agentic systems are used
for routine analysis,
standard reporting and
basic process optimization.
Now the humans look more
like operation teams,
account managers and business
intelligence analysts
providing operational
oversight, exception handling
and process improvement.
Agents and people are the ones now
that are co-creating
these rule-based workflows
as problem become better understood
and turn those into automation.
And then finally, as we
look at business compliance,
we even skew away from agentic
to even more automation
as we're now looking for
deterministic execution
against well understood problems.
Here, the human
contribution is that context
that Jonathan was talking about.
It's that dedicated expert
knowledge that's needed
for those human in the loop decisions.
And those situations where
rapidly evolving regulatory
and compliance frameworks can be digested
and understood in the
context of the business.
Taken as a whole.
This asymmetric approach
allows us to deploy
the right kinds of resources
to the right problems.
Like most approaches, it's not perfect,
but it's proving to be highly adaptable
a way to leverage this new technology.
And so our question for
you, how are you thinking
about team structure in agentic world?
Hopefully these ideas will
give you some new perspectives
as you apply them to your own space.
For another view on the
impact of agents on the work,
I'm excited to welcome to
the stage Richard Davis,
CTO of Danske Bank.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I actually forgot I was coming up here.
I was so engrossed in the presentation.
So, excuse me.
So I'm Richard Davis, as I said,
I'm the CTO at Danske Bank
and we're based in Copenhagen.
And Jonathan mentioned earlier
about 95% of organizations
not seeing value from GenAI yet.
And we actually think we are part
of the latter part of that equation
that are seeing the 5%
of real value from GenAI.
And today, I'm gonna
just touch upon our story
and some of the challenges we see
both from a technology perspective
and a human perspective.
But before I go into a bit more detail,
I'll just give you some background
of where we are at Danske Bank.
So we are a bank in the Copenhagen
and we have a rich 150-year history.
And we've been running
infrastructure on-prem
for many, many years.
And to date, it's given
us a lot of the value
that we've seen through
our banking systems.
But of course, as we
wanna become more agile,
we've introduced the public cloud
and we've gone from public,
from on-prem, sorry,
to the public cloud
and we've now migrated 850 applications
into AWS for the last 18 months.
But it's really been
around about mindset change
rather than just the technical change.
But also on top of that,
it's given us a great opportunity
when it comes to GenAI.
It's really given us the infrastructure
for us to adapt and deliver
really, really quick solutions
as well as things such as sandboxes.
So we say to ourselves
that we are catching up,
from catching up to winning a Danske Bank.
And it really is cloud
being our foundation
when it comes to delivering GenAI
and us becoming an agent workforce.
We really feel that we are
gonna become an AI-first bank.
People often say,
are you really gonna
put AI into Danske Bank?
But of course, we
already think it's there.
So yeah, it's a bit cheesy,
but you know, we had to do it.
Anyway, so as we've been delivering
GenAI into our organization,
we've got something we
now call 10 Big Wins.
We used to call them Big Bets, Big Rocks.
We're now saying that
we feel so passionate
that these things are gonna give us value,
that we're gonna deliver them
and they're called Big Wins.
Now, one of them I'm delivering
is around our product delivery lifecycle.
It was based on software
delivery lifecycle.
But as we've kind of gone through,
as we've rolled out AI coding assistance,
like I'm sure many of you've had,
we've seen a huge reduction
in our change lead time by about 50%.
So this is great,
huge amount of benefit to our developers.
But when we started
speaking to our developers,
we started doing a level of analysis
using our live engineering
tooling where we could see
all the different touch points
in our delivery life cycle.
And we've soon realized
that many of our developers,
we do have quite a few,
were actually working very, very hard,
but only 35% of their
time was spent on coding.
So a lot of the time,
they were working really, really hard,
but in other areas of delivery process.
So what we found was there was
one process for development,
but many, many other processes
across the organization.
And they were working hard,
working with the other processes.
And to a certain extent, if we move on,
when we asked them how they feeling,
well, they felt that
progress they were seeing
still didn't equal the level of effort
that they're putting in on a daily basis.
So where are we?
So we're on a journey to
what we call our new PDLC,
which is the product
development lifecycle.
We are actually looking at how we can look
at the development teams
that are stuck in processes
of endless Kanban boards,
handover meetings, documentation, testing,
all sorts of things like that.
And we feel there's a major opportunity
for us to deliver one agentic workflow
with zero friction
and to a certain extent tool.
So some of the agents that
we are starting to build,
we've actually put one
into production already,
we are starting to see
some immediate benefits from the agents.
The first one, I think
Jonathan mentioned earlier,
was around business analysis, BAs.
We have a large number of BAs,
but we also have a lot of
developers working on BA.
And so now we're looking
at how we can automate
the specs and validation
and reducing the manual
effort of our resources.
We're also looking at QA.
This testing, how can
we get an agent to start
accelerating the generation of test cases
and looking for the detection?
Now of course, we know
that a lot of people
don't like actually writing test scripts,
but they also don't want to
execute so many tests as well.
So this is, I think, something
that we think would
give us a lot of value.
And then, something
that's close to my heart
as an ex support person,
I think Jonathan mentioned
before about the 24 by 7
is really how do we start thinking
about reliability engineering agents?
This one really, really excites me.
So we already have something
called Cloud Buddy,
and I think we are gonna
rename it at some point,
but it actually sits in production today
and cuts triage time down by about 75%
and also improves our root cause accuracy.
We're also looking at how
this can actually help us
with incident resolution.
It doesn't actually perform an action,
but it actually helps us
going through log analysis, for example.
I'm pretty sure this agent, at some point,
is gonna be part of our organization.
In fact, as we are looking to give it
more and more tasks,
we're almost thinking
about how we can call it
a promotion for the agent.
But this is the first kinda wave
of agents that we are putting in our PDLC,
but we really think that at some point
we will have the complete agent framework
when it comes from having an idea
all the way through to running
the agent in production
and potentially even retiring the product.
So I've talked a little
bit about the technology,
I've talked a little bit
about the history of the bank.
One of the biggest things we've seen
is the change management,
the people element, the human resources.
And as I really, really feel
that there's a lot of
change management to happen.
And the reason is is because
there's a huge amount
of background of different generations,
cultures and experiences
across the organization.
Some are super excited with
the agentic opportunities
that we have and some not so much.
So we all know the corporate jargon.
The first one here, right?
I'll circle back to you, sounds harmless.
But what we really think this says is,
"Why should I be using
something that can replace me?"
Well, I think Jonathan
mentioned it already.
We actually tell them, look,
GenAI won't necessarily replace your role,
but people using GenAI potentially will.
Then there's the classic,
"Let's take it offline."
Now this one's okay, but
really what it means is,
"Look, sounds okay, but where do I start?
Do I really have the time to
start learning new tool sets?"
And this is where we have champions
that train the trainers
in our organization,
continue leaning in to the employees,
teaching them and giving them demos
of how others in the organization
are getting benefits.
And then finally, we have the supporters,
usually the kinda younger rats
who are really, really hungry
to use some of their anyway
tooling and the agents.
And really what they're saying is,
"It's really about time
we implemented some great processes here."
So this is something that we are seeing
across the organization.
So this is really around the resources,
but what does it mean for me as a CTO?
And I think this role is
continuing to evolve as well.
So we talked to about it earlier
about being the expert generalist.
And I don't think that actually me now
is not as deep in
technology as I used to be.
I see myself as a connector of experts
across both technology
and the wide employee.
This is where the magic happens
and really where platform,
technology, and processes align.
I did actually say that
I'm a man of many hats
and I didn't actually expect my team
to put this on the slide,
so I'll move on very, very quickly.
(audience chuckling)
But if there's anything I would say,
so there's a couple of things.
One is momentum being profession.
When we started off,
we really, really kept on planning,
we were planning, we were planning.
And by the time we
actually went to implement
any type of GenAI tooling
or agentic opportunities,
we really felt that it
had already moved on.
So we really felt that
we've got to get moving
really, really quick.
And what we started to do
with some GenAI hackathons.
Now with these GenAI hackathons,
what we did, we gave the end users,
the people in the front line
with some of the low-code
no-code tools that we have.
And we said, look, we guarantee you
a path into production for the winner.
Actually, we ended up at having three,
the top three solutions all
getting ready for production.
The winner called
CheckMate is in production
and it's actively used by this team
that delivered it in the hackathon
every day today, every day.
So the commitment that
we had said to people
about it going into production
has really, really driven
the hunger for people to get involved
and understand more about GenAI.
And then finally, we'd team up.
We've teamed up with a
number of great partners
and strategic supporters
across the organization.
Our CEO is mandating that the use of GenAI
and we continue to kinda
focus on the north star
with becoming an AI-first bank.
And then finally,
this isn't Jonathan and I,
this is actually just put together,
but we will actually just say,
"Look, as we partner up,
having that north star
and that end vision gives us something
for us to kind of focus upon."
Without further ado,
I'll hand it back to Jonathan, thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
Thank you very much for
listening to us today.
Thank you, Richard,
for sharing that story.
I love the hackathon idea
where we're gonna guarantee
it goes into production.
All of this is such a
fungible state right now,
such a fungible space.
It's changing every single day.
We wanted to give you
some deep snippets though,
on what's happening we see
happening with the roles
and in particularly what's
happening with Amazon.
Finally, please leave feedback for us.
I'm the track owner
for all the senior leader sessions today.
I will read every single comment
that you leave for us today.
We greatly appreciate the scores
and feedbacks you give us.
And with that, thank you very much
for listening to us today.